a long-awaited report into child sexual
abuse in football has found significant
institutional failings on the part of
the football association
and says the sports governing body put
children at risk
over a five-year period the sheldon
review was commissioned
in 2016 after several men waived their
right to anonymity to speak
about their experiences well one of the
most prolific offenders was the football
coach and convicted
pedophile barry bonnell the report found
that during his time at manchester city
senior management at the club were made
aware of rumors but didn't
investigate it adds that some members of
staff appear to have referred to him as
a kitty fiddler
it also concluded that abusers used the
colog the cloak of respectability to win
over boys and their parents and that the
men were manipulative
and used elaborate grooming practices
in later years between 1995 and 2000 the
review says the fa acted far
too slowly to introduce effective child
protection measures and that there were
significant institutional failings for
which there is no excuse
and i found that up until august 2020
there were 240
suspects of sexual abuse and at least
692 survivors
well our sports correspondent martha
kellner joins us live from
crew it's pretty damning isn't it martha
it certainly is as you mentioned there
survivors have waited an
awfully long time for the release of
this report
it was commissioned four years ago back
in 2016
when andy woodward became the first
footballer to wave his right to
anonymity
and reveal that he had suffered abuse by
barry bonnell that prolific
football sex abuser that we all now know
so much
about and now it has finally arrived
this report it's 707 pages long
it's exhaustive in its detail and it's
damning in its verdict particularly for
the football association while the
report
finds no evidence of a conspiracy or
collusion to cover up
within the football association it does
find that over a five-year period
between october 2000 and sorry i'll just
get those
dates for you between um october
1995 and may 2000 that five year period
that they consistently let down children
within
football clive sheldon qc the barrister
who authored the report wrote
the fa should have engaged more deeply
with the issue of child protection and
should have acted more quickly to bring
in comprehensive measures
to safeguard children in the game these
are significant
institutional failings for which there
is no
excuse now the report spoke to 62
survivors and
157 other individuals
it focuses on seven abusers barry
bonnell who was also
a football scout and coach here at crew
alexandra
also at manchester city but it also
focuses on six
other abusers the report identifies
historical
failings at several football clubs they
are chelsea
aston villa newcastle manchester city
crew alexandra where i am
stoke peterborough and southampton
now some survivors did provide testimony
to
to clive sheldon qc stating that they
believed
there was a pedophile ring within
football
clive sheldon accepted that some of
these perpetrators
may have known each other but he didn't
think that they acted together to abuse
young boys that is one of the key
findings of this report
some survivors also want to see
mandatory reporting
that would be a legal requirement for
those who know that abuse is going on
to report it to a higher authority clive
sheldon
qc said that was not within his remit
and now he did however
recommend 13 recommendations including
the publishing of a safeguarding report
every year and also an annual
safeguarding in football
day but clearly this is going to be a
highly emotional day
for the survivors of that abuse we may
call it historical abuse
but it's still very much having a
physical and psychological effect
on those survivors right up until the
present day
as you can see from an interview i did
earlier today um with david
lean who was a victim of barry bonnell
that's it it impacts you sort of every
day
it doesn't go away and you know i've
said this many times i can close my eyes
and put myself back into that room
it's that easy to do that you know and
so
um i wasn't three four five year old i
was 12
and you know i was at high school i've
got very vivid memories of exactly what
happened
um so yeah we live with it every day
people don't realise how
big an effect it takes on your whole
your whole family
yeah i wasn't um i wasn't
sort of planning on getting you know
emotional today i've spoke about it a
lot
um but yeah
it does
hugely emotional there from david lean
now one of the clubs which the report
focuses on is crew alexandra
where barry bernell spent many years and
committed
many offences against many young boys
the report finds that while there was no
obvious cover-up at crew alexandra
there were persistent rumors that barry
bonnell had a sexual
interest in children rumors which the
report concludes that some
coaches would probably have heard about
now dario grady was director of football
here up until 2019
he was also here at the time of barry
bernell's offending
um and we tried um to get a word with
with dario grady earlier
hello sir hi how are you
i'm
i'm under instructions sorry is there
any comment you'd like to make to the
victims
they've just said no sorry
bye
dario grady they're very reluctant to
comment but we do expect to hear from
the football association
later on today you would expect given
how damning the verdict is of this
report given
findings of institutional failings
within that organization
that five years which they were found to
have put to
put children playing football around the
country at risk
that it will force that organization the
national governing body for football
in this country into an apology an
apology that victims have waited an
awful long time for